[Music]
on this Sunday night touching tributes
it was a call to duty for her as one of
Canada's longest serving Mayors I love
to work Hazel mccallion has died plus
culture change how The Tyree Nichols
case
[Music]
is Reviving calls for reform in police
response across the U.S
Global News digs into the problems
pouring into aging Canadian Naval
vessels
and chiseled to Perfection you probably
have 30 000 pounds of ice here in town
the competing Carver is bringing warmth
with their ice cold creations
global national with Paul Nasser
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with the tributes
pouring in for hazel mccallion the
former mayor of Mississauga known by
many as Hurricane Hazel led the city for
12 terms a Trailblazer for women in
politics and a mentor to politicians she
touched the lives of millions in her 101
years of living life to its fullest
she was amazing and I went to so many
events with hazel and make no mistake
about it she was the star of the show no
matter who she was with
Ontario Premier Doug Ford was one of
many to pay his respects today recalling
their long personal and professional
relationship including one last Memento
he got from her assigned Formula One
with hazel steering the wheel as Taria
Israeli reports many agree her
leadership will be her Legacy
Hurricane Hazel was a force with her
dominating personality and political
invincibility a woman can do anything a
man can do that was not the prevailing
view when mccallion took office she ran
for mayor in 1978 as the underdog the
incumbent referred to her as a woman
wanting to get into a man's world ladies
and gentlemen
tonight she got in and stayed in for the
next 36 years she did it and we knew
that if Hazel mccallion could do it we
could do it too so she was an
inspiration for many of us in business
and in politics
mccallion was an inspiration to
generations of politicians transforming
a collection of quiet townships into a
major Metropolis she built the city of
Mississauga Mississauga is what it is
today because of Mayor Hazel mccallion
she was born on a farm in Quebec in 1921
and moved to Toronto to work with
engineering firm Canadian Kellogg during
the second world war before eventually
making Mississauga home as mayor she
faced a major leadership test early on
the planes were just incredible a CP
train carrying hazardous chemicals
derailed and exploded no one died in the
disaster and mccallion was credited for
her Swift response
she was known for her common touch and
straight talking style the person
without a job is not interested in
balancing the budget and became a
fixture in Municipal politics Not only
was she one of the most lovable people
in her own way but she was tough as
nails
so tough macallian outlasted seven
premiers and eight prime ministers Hazel
mccallion was a remarkable and inspiring
leader
an extraordinary woman and a really good
friend in her long career there were
also low points mccallion was accused of
failing to disclose a conflict of
interest involving her son in a case
that was ultimately dismissed
her biographer believed she will be
remembered most as a political
pragmatist she had this remarkable
ability better than any politician I've
known or studied to feel the public
pulse to kind of sense the public mood
and living actively to 101 she was also
a symbol for healthy aging this idea
about age I just don't buy it a
hurricane who left her Mark in
Mississauga and across the country
tariya isri Global News Ottawa
to the U.S now where there are
widespread calls for Congress to reform
policing across the country over the
death of 29 year old Tyree Nichols who
was severely beaten by police in
Tennessee five now former officers have
been charged with second-degree murder
in Nichols death the special unit they
were a part of has also been disbanded
but as Jennifer Johnson reports
Republicans are already pushing back on
the calls for National change
after the police body cam video of the
brutal beating of Tyree Nichols went
public calls are growing louder for
Congress to take action finally passed
the George Floyd Justice and policing
act to improve police training and ban
certain potentially deadly practices
shame on us if we don't use his tragic
death
to finally get the George Floyd Justice
and police and act passed Federal
lawmakers haven't passed sweeping
policing reform in decades even as
violent deaths at the hands of law
enforcement shocked the world but top
Republicans in the house are taking the
same route they have on gun control that
nothing can be done no amount of
training is going to change what we saw
in that media these individuals these
five individuals did not have any
respect for Life
protesters who have taken to the streets
across the country feel differently I
feel like
that we have to stand up for Injustice
and we have to have police reform this
cannot keep happening memphis's police
chief has decided to disband the
Department's so-called scorpion unit
which was designed to crack down on
Street crime a move many City residents
applauded
all five former officers were part of
that group there have been scattered
reports of abuses by the Scorpion unit
and then nationally you know some of
these uh quick swarm suppression
specialty units sometimes can lead to
over aggressive tactics unlike what
happened to George Floyd in Minnesota
the five former officers in this case
were all black experts say while
America's City police forces are getting
more Diversified greater changes have to
be made
simply diversifying sworn officer
rosters is insufficient if there is not
structural change to make things fairer
and more just U.S President Joe Biden
has called on Congress to pass the
George Floyd act but it failed after
Floyd's shocking death and many believe
it will fail again
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
today marks the sixth anniversary of the
shooting inside a Quebec City mosque a
ceremony took place this evening inside
the very mosque prayer room where the
Rampage happened this along with other
events across the province commemorating
the tragedy with survivors and
supporters gathering in solidarity a
lone gunman walked into the place of
worship in 2017 killing six worshipers
and wounding several others the gunman
who pled guilty was sentenced to life in
prison although a Supreme Court ruling
allows him to apply for parole after 25
years
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu says Israel will respond to
attacks against its citizens with an
iron fist but that he's not seeking an
escalation cabinet approves several
reforms in response to the shooting
deaths of seven Israelis outside a
synagogue on Friday one of which include
making it easier for Israelis to obtain
permits to carry guns a move Netanyahu
says will reduce gun violence it's been
a year of increasing tensions between
Israel and Palestine with an
unprecedented number of Palestinian
civilians and militants being killed
Netanyahu has also been brought back to
lead the most right-wing government in
the country's history the UN and U.S
have condemned the rise in fatal attacks
with Anthony blinken's upcoming trip to
Jerusalem this week set to focus on
efforts to ease tensions
all right
this eyewitness video reportedly shows
the moment a drone strike hit a military
Factory in Iran there are no reports of
injuries and the defense Ministry says
it was able to shoot down other drones
targeting the site the unclaimed attack
is being referred to by the foreign
minister as an attempt to create
instability in the country
violent clashes with riot police in Lima
left at least one protester dead as
weeks of anti-government demonstrations
continue in Peru
[Applause]
foreign
police used tear gas to disperse people
in the latest round of demonstrations
which have been ongoing since early
December after weeks of demonstrations
in rural regions protesters have
descended on the Peruvian Capital as
they call for the current president to
step down and demand fresh elections
more than 50 deaths have now been
connected to the protests according to
Human Rights activists
two Halifax now where there's renewed
concern over aging Canadian Naval
vessels the Royal Canadian Navy suggests
a parts failure causing flooding on
board hmcs Summerside on January 20th
was minor but the alarming incident was
only revealed after global news began
asking questions and as Ross Lord
reports military analysts say taxpayers
should expect more of these problems as
navy ships are stretched beyond their
original purpose and life expectancy
sometimes trouble happens when you least
expect it that's the case with the
Navy's hmcs Summer Side the ship spent
four months in the Baltic Sea and the
North Atlantic opposing Russian
aggression without reporting any notable
incidents then as Summerside was tied up
at the Halifax Naval dockyard last
Friday there was cause for concern a
global news source whose information has
been confirmed by the Navy says the ship
began taking on water and started
listing in a statement commanding
officer Richard Crowder says water
flooded down into several compartments
including some cabins the ward room and
the Machinery control room Crowder says
the likely source of the leak was a pipe
fitting that failed he says the valve
failure has been initially assessed as
being due to corrosion and that's where
much of the concern lies it's a valve
failure on a 25 year old ship
and that ship was only meant to last 25
years so things like that are
characteristic of old ships the
Summerside is the youngest of 12 coastal
defense vessels that retired Navy
Commander Ken Hansen notes are
increasingly being used to fill in for
larger Canadian Patrol frigates when the
military's reach exceeds its grasp the
12 frigates are even older and they've
been doing double duty since the Navy's
Fleet of Destroyers was retired several
years ago the good news the leak was
detected and stopped before slight
listing turned into something worse this
was manageable with good leadership and
good teams and good procedures the Navy
says there's no damage to Mechanical or
electrical systems but with corrosion
and other problems more common after
ships go beyond their life expectancy
military analysts say more trouble is
inevitable Ross Lord Global News Halifax
coming up the Avalanche season's deadly
start
the mountains are beautiful but
particularly perilous
Heather urich's West near Kenmore
Alberta I'll have more on why this
Avalanche season is off to such a deadly
start ahead
[Music]
a warning for Back Country enthusiasts
in Alberta and BC the risk of deadly
Avalanches is at a 20-year High a
stretch of cold and dry weather back in
November means the snowpack is unstable
throughout the region as Heather urac's
West explains in the last few weeks
alone snow slides have already killed
five people
for David Stark there are few sounds
more terrifying than the crash of an
avalanche it's so distinct and uh as
loud as thunderous sometimes it's a
crack depends on the size and magnitude
of the Avalanche but it's a it's a
fearsome sound
it's why Stark's Team Works to train 800
Backcountry users every year on
Avalanche safety but this year he
worries safety training may not be
enough we're all quite worried about it
we're all paying attention to what's
happening with the Avalanche conditions
and we're being really careful that's
because is the snow blanketing much of
the mountains in BC and Alberta is
sitting precariously on a very unstable
layer formed by a stretch of cold and
dry weather last November this type of
instability or this type of weakness
doesn't go away in a hurry and so we
expect it to be here for the long term
snowpack conditions are so unstable that
this winter is being compared to 2003.
that Avalanche season claimed 29 lives
this year's Avalanche season has so far
killed five including Constable Wade
titamore and Constable matu nolay two
off-duty police officers who died after
a slide on January 9th near caslow BC a
third person a snowmobiler was killed
after an avalanche in Belmont on January
21st then two days later American
Brothers Jonathan and Timothy Kinsley
died after being buried while hella
skiing near Revelstoke BC the best
strategy for managing an avalanche
problem like this man a deeper system
slab problem is avoidance so avoiding
High consequence slopes avoiding steep
terrain get the training have a process
when you go out so pay attention to what
Avalanche Canada says read the bulletins
and then dial back on the train
so much risk
way to keep battery users safe
everyone out of Harm's Way Heather
York's West Global News near Kenmore
Alberta
four people are confirmed to have died
after extensive flooding in New Zealand
Auckland New Zealand's largest city has
been battered by rain since Friday and
remains under a state of emergency in
just 15 hours the city was hit with 75
percent of its seasonal rainfall the
country's climate science body says
Global heating is causing these types of
weather events to become increasingly
common and intense the severe weather is
expected to continue into Monday
[Music]
ahead Novak Djokovic adds to his
legendary career by coming out on top
down under
foreign
Djokovic has done it again at the
Australian Open winning the final in
straight sets to claim a record
extending 10th title the Serbian tennis
star was dominant throughout the
tournament dropping just one set across
seven matches despite playing through a
nagging hamstring injury Djokovic is now
tied with Rafael Nadal with 22 Grand
Slam championships the most by any male
tennis player and has not lost at
Melbourne Park since 2018.
back here in Canada there are more pleas
for action and accountability in sports
in a new open letter dozens of Scholars
are joining a chorus of calls for an
independent inquiry into the abuse
suffered by Canadian athletes as
Catherine urquhart reports they're also
demanding the Federal Government Act on
what they call a system that's enabling
the problem
in 2022 former team Canada and White Cap
soccer coach Bob berarda was convicted
of three counts of sexually assaulting
teenage soccer players and handed a
sentence of two years less a day
whistleblower Kira McCormack told a
House of Commons Committee hearing on
abuse in sport that complaints were
covered up both the Whitecaps in Canada
Soccer covered up Brothers
October 2008 termination presenting it
publicly as a mutual parting of ways
which allowed him to go back and Coach
teenage girls for another 11 years
McCormack called for a Judicial inquiry
now joining her the group Scholars
against abuse in Canadian sport its 91
members from 30 Canadian and 17
International institutions have sent an
open letter to prime minister Trudeau
demanding an independent judicial
inquiry into the widespread reports of
sexual physical and psychological abuse
of athletes throughout the nation's
Sports system there needs to be
something that digs deeper and looks uh
more at the preventative side of things
Macintosh Ross and others who signed the
letter say they're seeking immediate
accountability and meaningful change
from sport Canada and the broader system
it governs this as they push for
systemic change in all sports where
abuse is being reported whether it be
soccer hockey or gymnastics we need to
just examine the whole thing from start
to finish because in 1989 I mean we did
it over steroids so if we're going to do
it over steroids surely we can do it
over child abuse minister of sport
Pascal stage has stated her office is
taking the issue extremely seriously
noting establishment of Canada's Office
of the sport Integrity commissioner but
those raising concerns maintain a
Judicial inquiry is the best way to
tackle the problem and if we are serious
about eradicating abuse and we have to
start treating the sport crisis as a
human rights crisis it is and Implement
change to make accountability
transparency integrity and basic human
rights at the heart of our system A
system that survivors say has enabled
Predators like Bob berarda to continue
targeting and abusing athletes Catherine
urquhart Global News Vancouver
next the massive Ice Creations being
chiseled to perfection
[Music]
Canada Post has unveiled its latest
stamp today to commemorate Black History
Month it pays tribute to Chloe Cooley a
black woman who lived in 18th century
Upper Canada known for her Defiance
against her captor Cooley resisted her
enslavement however she could but
eventually she was abducted and sold as
a slave to the U.S witness accounts of
her capture and struggle were used to
introduce Canada's first anti-slavery
law the law set the stage for the ending
of enslavement in Upper Canada as well
as creating a legal refuge for those
fleeing slavery in other countries
a yearly tradition is wrapping up in
Atlantic Canada as artists from across
the maritimes took part in an ice
sculpting Festival in Nova Scotia
organizers say the event was inspired by
an annual Winter Carnival from decades
ago which featured horse races ice
skating and more but it hasn't happened
since their Winters became warmer and as
Megan King reports the cool carvings are
now an Ode to the carnival that once was
it takes a lot of chipping brushing
sawing and melting to shape these ice
sculptures a task eight Carvers from all
over the maritimes are taking on as part
of the downtown Dartmouth Ice Festival
they come from three different
disciplines some of them are fine arts
artists so they sculpt
some of them are culinary chefs so they
these are the kind of ice sculptures you
might see at a banquet and then we have
some chainsaw Carvers which is kind of
exciting because they're roaring the
chainsaws and the the little ice
fragments the snow is flying the annual
event takes a lot of work and a lot of
ice we shipped the maybe 20 pallets so
you probably have 30 000 pounds of ice
here in town chef and Carver Richard
shiesong has been using ice sculpting as
part of his culinary arts since 1979 and
not only does he sculpt ice for this
Festival he makes it this is the largest
ice carving activity in the Atlantic
region and no matter who wants ice
carvings in the three Atlantic region it
always ends up on my desk because I'm
the only producer of ice in the maritime
each square or rectangle here is a block
of ice Nova Scotia based artist called
Roselle spends more than 10 hours on his
sculpture after planning with drawings
and Miniatures carving ice is fun it's
uh
you got a little more forgiveness like
uh you can heat it with a torch and you
get this nice Crystal magical finish
um it's it's brittle but it doesn't have
a grain per se so
um it's easier to carve for the festival
he's carving the image of a drum dancer
honoring a friend from his time living
in Nunavut Matthew is a drum dancer
known worldwide and so I decided to make
a drum dancer and and uh respect towards
you the artist successfully took on the
cool commission finishing more than 40
sculptures Megan King Global News
Halifax
and that is global national for this
Sunday night I'm nitu garcha tonight
dear Canada is Banff Alberta we love
seeing your Canada please keep emailing
your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks so much for
watching Donna will be back with you
tomorrow have a great night